This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The story we're about to tell is pretty much the worst thing a parent can imagine. We were awakened by the phone ringing. That's Noreen gosh. It was early on a Sunday morning in 1982 in Des Moines, Iowa. Noreen's son Johnny had left for his regular paper route. It was the neighbors saying they did not receive their newspapers. 92 in Des Moines, Iowa. Nareen Sun Johnny had left for his regular paper route. It was the neighbors saying they did not receive their newspapers. This wasn't like Johnny. He'd been a paper boy for years.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们要讲的故事几乎是父母能想象到的最糟糕的事情。我们被电话铃声吵醒了。那是诺琳·戈什。那是1982年一个周日的清晨，在爱荷华州得梅因。诺琳的儿子约翰尼出门去送他例行的报纸。是邻居打来的，说他们没有收到报纸。州得梅因。纳雷恩的儿子约翰尼已经去送他惯常的送报路线了。是邻居说他们没有收到报纸。这可不像约翰尼的作风。他当送报童已经好几年了。
He'd never missed a delivery. His dad got up and said I'll go help him finish the route. He's probably just running late. He went up the street and that's where he saw Johnny's wagon sitting. Johnny's red wagon was sitting at the corner. It was still full of newspapers. He rushed back and told me, Johnny was gone and called the police. Johnny Gosh was 13 when he disappeared.
他从未漏过一次投递。他爸爸起来说，我去帮他把剩下的路线送完。他可能只是迟到了。他沿着街道走去，就在那里他看到了约翰尼的手推车。约翰尼的红色手推车停在拐角处。里面还装满了报纸。他跑回来告诉我，约翰尼不见了，并报了警。约翰尼·戈什失踪时只有13岁。
He had blue eyes and dirty blonde hair with a small gap between his front teeth. And his would be the first face of a missing child ever printed on a milk carton. It's been 30 years since these milk cartons came and went. I wasn't even alive to see them, but I still know about the faces on the milk cartons. That's reporter Annie Brown.
他有一双蓝色的眼睛和一头脏金色头发，门牙之间有一个小缝隙。他将成为第一个被印在牛奶盒上的失踪儿童的面孔。自从这些牛奶盒出现又消失已经过去30年了。我甚至还没出生，没亲眼见过它们，但我依然知道牛奶盒上的那些面孔。那是记者安妮·布朗。
The image of a missing child on a milk carton became iconic, a kind of cultural shorthand for missing children. And even though this image has stuck around for three decades, the actual milk carton campaign only lasted two years, and it was largely unsuccessful at locating the kids on the cartons. The morning that Johnny disappeared, Nareen said it took 45 minutes for the police to arrive, so she called around to the other boys who delivered papers that morning. She found five witnesses that saw her son
牛奶盒上失踪儿童的形象成了一个标志，一种关于失踪儿童的文化简写。尽管这个形象已经存在了三十年，但实际的牛奶盒活动只持续了两年，并且在寻找盒上的孩子方面基本上没有成功。约翰尼失踪的那天早上，诺琳说警察花了45分钟才赶到，于是她给那天早上送报的其他男孩打了电话。她找到了五个目击者，他们看到她的儿子
talking to a man in a blue van. She relayed this to the police. The cop looked at me and said, well, has your son ever run away before? And I said, well, no, he's never run away ever nor did he run away today. But the police were skeptical. This was Iowa. This kind of thing wasn't supposed to happen to kids like Johnny in places like Iowa. We'd never had a crime like this before. This was before Amber Alerts, before those text messages that you get when a kid goes missing. There wasn't even a category for missing children. Kids were put in the same group as missing adults and an adult had to
和一个开着蓝色货车的男人在说话。她把这个情况转告给了警察。警察看着我说：“嗯，你儿子以前离家出走过吗？”我说：“没有，他从来没有离家出走过，今天也没有。”但警察持怀疑态度。这里是爱荷华州。这种事本不该发生像约翰尼这样的孩子身上，在爱荷华州这样的小地方。我们以前从未发生过这样的犯罪。这是在安珀警报出现之前，在孩子失踪时你会收到的那些短信出现之前。当时甚至没有失踪儿童这一分类。孩子们和失踪成年人被归为同一类，而成年人必须
be gone for three days before they were considered missing. Without the police's help, Johnny's parents tried everything they could on their own. They hired private investigators and coordinated search parties. Meanwhile, as they searched, they also wrote Iowa State legislation that would differentiate missing children
失踪三天才能被视为失踪人员。在没有警察帮助的情况下，约翰尼的父母尽他们所能独自尝试了一切。他们雇佣了私家侦探并协调搜救队。与此同时，在搜寻的过程中，他们还起草了爱荷华州立法，旨在将失踪儿童
from missing adults. I wrote the John Agash Law at my kitchen table. But after all of this, Nareen Gash's son was still gone. And then, two years later, in 1984, another little boy disappeared while delivering newspapers. He lived in a neighborhood not far from John's. Jean Martin was last seen delivering newspapers between 5.30 and 6.00 that morning. His paper bag with newspapers still inside was found just outside of Des Moines. This second paper boy had a relative who worked at a local dairy, the Anderson and Ericsson dairy.
与失踪成年人区分开来。我在厨房的桌子上写下了《约翰·阿戈什法案》。但经过这一切之后，诺琳·戈什的儿子依然不见踪影。然后，两年后的1984年，又有一个小男孩在送报纸时失踪了。他住在离约翰家不远的一个街区。让·马丁最后一次被人看到是在那天早上5点30分到6点之间送报纸。他装有报纸的纸袋仍然完好地放在得梅因郊外。第二个送报童有一个亲戚在当地的一家乳品厂工作，即安德森和埃里克森乳品厂。
The relative and the dairy's owner came up with an idea to help find these boys. The Anderson-Ariks and Dairy contacted each family, and they wanted to do something helpful in the investigations. The families of the missing boys agreed, and within a few short weeks, thousands of milk cartons were rolled out of trucks and inter-grotary stores all over Des Moines. As clerks stocked their shelves, the faces of Johnny Gosh and Eugene Martin smiled back.
这位亲戚和乳品厂老板想出了一个主意，来帮助寻找这些男孩。安德森-埃里克森乳品厂联系了每个家庭，他们想在调查中做一些有帮助的事情。失踪男孩的家属们表示同意，短短几周内，数千个牛奶盒从卡车上卸下，送入了得梅因各地的杂货店。当店员们往货架上摆货时，约翰尼·戈什和尤金·马丁的面孔微笑着回望着他们。
The campaign started out at one local dairy, but over the next few weeks it spread to other Midwestern towns. In Illinois, Dairy saw it and said, hey, why don't we try that? And from there, it went national. Nearly everybody drinks milk. Milk turns over quickly so we could put a lot of different kids photos on and pull children's off that needed to come off. At a moment's notice. That's Barbara Huggett. She was working as an artist at the National Child Safety
这场活动最初只在当地一家乳品厂开展，但在接下来的几周里，它蔓延到了中西部的其他城镇。伊利诺伊州的乳品厂看到后说：“嘿，我们为什么不也试试呢？”从那里开始，它走向了全国。几乎每个人都喝牛奶。牛奶周转很快，所以我们可以把很多不同孩子的照片放上去，并在需要时把那些不再需要的孩子的照片撤下来。随时随地。那是芭芭拉·赫格特。当全国牛奶盒活动兴起时，她在密歇根州的全国儿童安全
Council in Michigan when the National Milk Carton Campaign took off. Our founder, apparently he'd seen Johnny Gashin, Eugene Martin on the Anderson, Erickson, Dairy Milk cartons. But he felt that the program should be nationwide. A nationwide milk carton campaign would alert families in California to look for a child who went missing in Iowa. The national campaign brought together local groups looking for missing children, and together they came up with a list of 77 kids from all over the country.
委员会担任美工。我们的创始人显然是在安德森-埃里克森乳品厂的牛奶盒上看到了约翰尼·戈什和尤金·马丁。但他觉得这个项目应该在全国范围内推广。全国范围内的牛奶盒活动将提醒加利福尼亚州的家庭寻找一个在爱荷华州失踪的孩子。全国活动将寻找失踪儿童的地方组织联合起来，他们共同列出了一份来自全国各地的77名儿童的名单。
We used cases that were believed to be what they termed in those days danger stranger abductions. In other words, kids that weren't taken by someone they knew. Barb's team didn't have computers, so they cut and arranged all 77 layouts by hand. We designed a layout that was just, you know, rather simple. In black block letters, the word missing was printed across the top of each waxy paper panel. Photos of two children relate side by side in black and white. Under the photos were their dates of birth, height, weight, and where they were
我们使用的是那些被认为是他们那个时代所称的“危险陌生人绑架”的案件。换句话说，不是被他们认识的人带走的儿童。芭芭拉的团队没有电脑，所以他们手工剪辑并排版了全部77个版面。我们设计了一个版面，就是那种，你知道的，比较简单的版面。在每个蜡纸板的顶部，用黑色的粗体字印着“失踪”这个词。两个孩子的照片黑白相间地并排贴着。照片下方是他们的出生日期、身高、体重以及他们
last seen. They also printed the pictures on school milk cartons but only one child could fit on those. Barb reached out to Darry's all over the country, asking if they'd be a part of the campaign. Within months, 700 independent Derry's had signed on. Boy, I wish I knew how many cartons had circulated. I imagine it's way into the billions. When you have 700, 750 Derry's printing day in and day out
最后一次被看到的地方。他们还在学校的牛奶盒上印刷了这些照片，但上面只能容纳一个孩子。芭芭拉联系了全国各地的乳品厂，询问他们是否愿意参与这项活动。几个月内，700家独立的乳品厂加入了进来。天哪，我真希望能知道发行了多少个纸盒。我猜足足有数十亿个。当你拥有700到750家乳品厂日复一日地印刷
for years. Some sources have estimated that as many as five billion milk cartons were printed with the faces of missing children. 200 missing children were featured on milk cartons as part of the campaign led by the National Child Safety Council, too, were found alive. One was a kid named Bobby Smith, Jr. Barb still remembers when she got the call
多年。一些消息来源估计，有多达五十亿个牛奶盒印上了失踪儿童的面孔。在全国儿童安全委员会领导的活动中，有200名失踪儿童的照片被印在牛奶盒上，其中有两人被活着找到。其中一个是叫小博比·史密斯的男孩。芭芭拉依然记得她接到关于博比的电话时的情景
about Bobby. After we'd gotten the word that the child had been found, it was just a sense of of elation and you wanted to let everyone in the building that had mailed it, boxed it, shipped it, you know, you just wanted to tell everyone who had touched it that that was worthwhile. You could hear the cheer throughout the whole building. Yay, we found a child, it was wonderful, you know. But Bobby Smith wasn't found because of the milk carton. Bobby was found by coincidence. His kidnapper's car had been involved in an accident.
。在我们接到孩子被找到的消息后，那真是一种欣喜若狂的感觉，你会想要告诉大楼里所有那些曾经打包、装箱、发货的人，你知道的，你只想告诉每一个经手过这件事的人，这一切都是值得的。你能听到整个大楼里此起彼伏的欢呼声。耶，我们找到了一个孩子，这太棒了，你知道的。但博比·史密斯并不是因为牛奶盒而被找到的。博比是偶然被找到的。他绑架者的汽车卷入了一场事故。
And when the police came looking for the owner of the car, they found Bobby. The other child found alive was a girl named Cheryl Lynn Kramer, but most of the kids featured in the national campaign and in the smaller local ones were never found. Unfortunately, the leads from the milk cartons did not reveal where Johnny's location was. That's Noreen Gosh again. Her son, Johnny, was never found. But Barbara Huggett and Noreen Goss are both adamant that the campaign had a positive impact.
当警察来寻找车主时，他们找到了博比。另一个被活着找到的孩子是一个名叫谢丽尔·林恩·克拉默的女孩，但全国活动以及规模较小的本地活动中特色展示的大多数孩子再也没有被找到。不幸的是，来自牛奶盒的线索并没有透露约翰尼的下落。那是诺琳·戈什再次发声。她的儿子约翰尼再也没有被找到。但芭芭拉·赫格特和诺琳·戈什都坚信，这项活动产生了积极的影响。
What it did was promote more awareness, so that people were looking if they saw a child that looked like they were in distress. Maybe you questioned whether or not those were the parents. During the Milk Carton Campaign, the Missing Children Assistance Act was passed. It established a federal program to find missing kids. Changing the rules for children when they're missing, not having to wait the hours and days. And mostly the Milk Cartons just got people thinking about kidnapping. That this could happen to your kid.
它所做的是提高了人们的意识，让人们在看到一个看起来处于痛苦之中的孩子时会去关注。也许你会质疑那是不是他们的父母。在牛奶盒活动期间，《失踪儿童援助法案》通过了。它建立了一个寻找失踪儿童的联邦项目。改变了儿童失踪时的规则，不必再等待那些小时和天数。最重要的是，牛奶盒只是让人们开始思考绑架问题。这种事可能会发生在你的孩子身上。
I have talked to quite a number of adults and they could remember their mom putting the milk carton on the kitchen table and saying, now, we're going to go over the rules again. And they would use the example of the boys on the milk carton. And make the correlation between that child and their child's life. In other words, the faces on the milk cartons scared the hell out of everyone. Which ultimately led to the campaign's downfall. Almost as quickly as it began, the milk carton campaign started by the National Child Safety Council ended.
我和相当多的成年人交谈过，他们还记得他们的妈妈把牛奶盒放在厨房桌子上说：“现在，我们要重新过一遍规则。”他们会用牛奶盒上的男孩作为例子。并在那个孩子和他们自己孩子的生活之间建立联系。换句话说，牛奶盒上的面孔把所有人都吓坏了。这最终导致了该活动的没落。几乎在它开始的同时，由全国儿童安全委员会发起的牛奶盒活动就结束了。
Just two years after the first milk cartons were printed, Derrys began to pull the missing kids' pictures from their side panels. One reason, of course, with the cartons is that the industry shifted to plastic. But Derrys also started to get tired of the depressing message. They took it away because there were people that were complaining that they thought
就在第一批牛奶盒印刷仅仅两年后，乳品厂开始将失踪儿童的照片从侧面板上撤下来。当然，纸盒被撤下的一个原因是行业转向了塑料制品。但乳品厂也开始厌倦这种令人沮丧的信息。他们把照片撤下了，因为有人抱怨说他们认为
it might scare children at the breakfast table. The famous pediatrician, Dr. Benjamin Spock, wrote columns condemning the milk carton campaign. It was traumatizing, he said. Kids shouldn't have to face that over their lucky charms. They see these missing kids kind of staring at them. That milk carton almost demands them to have that conversation.
这可能会在早餐桌上吓到儿童。著名的儿科医生本杰明·斯波克博士撰写专栏谴责牛奶盒活动。他说，这是具有创伤性的。孩子们不应该在吃幸运符麦片时面对这些。他们看到这些失踪的孩子仿佛在盯着他们看。那个牛奶盒几乎迫使他们进行那样的对话。
What to do if you see a stranger or a stranger costs you. That's Paul Morsicchi-Rinfrow. He's a historian at the University of Iowa who's been writing his dissertation on child safety on the milk carton kids and their effect on us. He believes the milk carton campaign reflected a larger fear that was gripping society at the time. Stranger danger. Paul studies the way that child safety was talked about at this time. In the news on the radio by politicians, and he says that this fear of stranger danger was exploding. Folks are kicking around these numbers that are just astronomical.
如果看到陌生人或陌生人靠近你该怎么办。那是保罗·莫尔西基-林弗罗。他是爱荷华大学的一名历史学家，一直在撰写关于牛奶盒儿童的儿童安全及其对我们影响的博士论文。他认为牛奶盒活动反映了当时笼罩社会的更广泛的恐惧。陌生人危险。保罗研究了当时人们谈论儿童安全的方式。在新闻中、广播里、由政客们谈论，他说这种对陌生人危险的恐惧正在爆炸式增长。人们到处散播那些简直是天文数字的数字。
Folks are saying there are 1.8 million missing children in the United States, and missing becomes very closely attached to abducted by strangers. But that just wasn't true. Every year, 800,000 kids are reported missing to the authorities. That's around 2,000 every day. But, a report from the Department of Justice found that the number of kids taken by strangers every year is only about 115. The Milk Carton campaign led by the National Child Safety Council focused on kids who
人们说美国有180万失踪儿童，而“失踪”这个词与“被陌生人绑架”紧密地联系在了一起。但事实并非如此。每年有80万儿童被向当局报告失踪。那大约每天2000起。但是，司法部的一份报告发现，每年被陌生人带走的儿童数量其实只有大约115人。由全国儿童安全委员会领导的牛奶盒活动主要关注那些
were kidnapped by strangers, and they were criticized for this. But there were also smaller, more localized campaigns going on that weren't bound by this rule. It was one of these smaller campaigns that ended up featuring the face of a missing girl named Bonnie Lomon. I wasn't kidnapped by strangers, I was kidnapped by people that loved me. Bonnie Lomon was kidnapped by her mother when she was three, after her parents got divorced. Even though she wasn't kidnapped by a stranger, Bonnie's dad had managed to get her on a milk carton. Bonnie had no idea that she had been kidnapped,
被陌生人绑架的儿童，他们因此受到了批评。但当时还有一些规模较小、更本地化的活动在进行，它们不受这条规则的束缚。正是其中一个规模较小的活动最终印上了一个名叫邦妮·洛蒙的失踪女孩的面孔。我不是被陌生人绑架的，我是被爱我的人绑架的。邦妮·洛蒙在她三岁父母离婚后，被她的母亲绑架了。尽管她不是被陌生人绑架的，但邦妮的爸爸还是设法把她弄上了牛奶盒。邦妮根本不知道自己曾被绑架，
but her childhood was pretty strange. After taking Bonnie, her mom and stepdad went to Sipan, a tiny island near Guam. Yeah, yeah, we lived in the woods, like in a shack. After a year in Sipan, next was Hawaii, but there was still line pretty low. We stayed inside all the time in Hawaii. I recall maybe one or two times being outside. Finally, they ended up in Colorado, and her mom and stepdad started to relax a bit.
但她的童年相当奇特。带走邦妮后，她妈妈和继父去了塞班岛，那是关岛附近的一个小岛。对，对，我们住在树林里，就像在一个棚屋里。在塞班岛呆了一年后，接下来是夏威夷，但我们仍然保持低调。我们在夏威夷总是待在室内。我记得大概有一两次去过外面。最后，他们到了科罗拉多州，她妈妈和继父开始稍微放松了一些。
The next were neighbors had a bunch of kids, and Bonnie played at their house all the time. We would play Barbie using I had my little Barbie case and I would bring that over. Aside from going to her neighbors, Bonnie was hardly ever allowed to leave the house, but on an unusual occasion her stepdad took her to the supermarket. They needed milk. I just remember looking and seeing how many cartons of milk there were. Like nowadays it's like whatever brand it is would be facing you, whereas at that time all the pictures were facing you. He grabbed the milk.
接下来是邻居家有一群孩子，邦妮经常去他们家玩。我们会玩芭比娃娃，我带着我小小的芭比箱子过去。除了去邻居家，邦妮几乎从不允许离开房子，但在一个不寻常的场合，她的继父带她去了超市。他们需要牛奶。我只记得看着并看到有多少盒牛奶。就像现在那样，不管什么牌子都会正面朝向你，而当时所有的照片都正面朝向你。他抓起牛奶。
He's like, hey, do you know who that is? Hey, you're famous. And I saw myself and I was like, oh, is that me? And he was like, oh, shush. Yes, Bonnie actually saw her own face on a milk carton. Though she had no idea what it meant at the time, Bonnie's stepdad bought the milk carton. And when they finished it, he asked her,
他说，嘿，你知道那是谁吗？嘿，你出名了。我看到我自己，然后我想，哦，那是我吗？他就像，哦，嘘。是的，邦妮实际上在牛奶盒上看到了她自己的脸。虽然她当时不知道这意味着什么，但邦妮的继父买下了那个牛奶盒。当他们喝完后，他问她：
Do you want it? You want to keep it? And so I remember cutting it out and being like, whoa, and staring at the picture. My hair was like in a little ponytail on the side, and I was wearing this little dress. He's like, now you got to keep it in, you know, a safe place. And I must have tossed it in my Barbie case. Looking back now, Bonnie sees her stepdad's actions as arrogance.
你想要吗？你想留着它吗？所以我记得把它剪下来，然后想，哇，盯着那张照片看。我的头发扎在侧面像一个小马尾辫，我穿着这件小连衣裙。他说，现在你得把它保存在一个安全的地方，你知道的。我一定把它扔进我的芭比箱子里了。现在回想起来，邦妮认为她继父的行为是一种傲慢。
He was so confident in himself that he could show me that because nothing's going to happen with it. But the next time Bonnie was at the neighbor's house, she left her Barbie case there. With the picture, she cut out of her own face on a milk carton. I remember there a lot of police showing up, a lot of police showing up. Within hours of the neighbor finding the picture,
他对自己的信心十足，认为可以把那个给我看，因为不会发生任何事情。但下次邦妮去邻居家时，她把芭比箱子落在那儿了。里面装着她从牛奶盒上剪下来的自己的脸的照片。我记得有很多警察出现，有很多警察出现。在邻居发现照片后的几个小时内，
police had swarmed Bonnie's home. She was whisked away and returned to her father. She was seven at the time. But their reunion wasn't easy at first. I remember being scared because I didn't know my dad, and all I wanted to do was be with her kind of sucked, you know. Bonnie is very clear that her mother loved her, But what she didn't know then was that she'd been denied some pretty basic pieces of her childhood. In the three and a half years she was missing, Bonnie didn't go to school. She hadn't learned to read.
警察包围了邦妮的家。她被迅速带走并送回了她的父亲身边。她当时七岁。但他们的重聚一开始并不容易。我记得我很害怕，因为我不认识我爸爸，我只想和她在一起，这感觉有点糟，你知道的。邦妮很清楚她母亲爱她，但她当时不知道的是，她被剥夺了童年中一些相当基础的东西。在她失踪的三、四年半里，邦妮没有去上学。她没有学会阅读。
I know I didn't read then because I would have realized that I was missing because on the picture it actually said missing child and then my name and the date. After returning to her dad, Bonnie had a pretty normal life. She started school, went on to college and eventually became a nurse. She has two kids now. She's really happy. She's one of the Milk Carton campaign's few success stories. I believe that I am who I am because I was on a milk carton and I was found and I had opportunities that with my dad growing up that I might not have had with my mom. I was able to live a great life and I'm grateful for it. After only two years the milk carton campaign had ended, but the faces
我知道我当时不会阅读，因为如果会的话，我就会意识到我失踪了，因为照片上实际上写着“失踪儿童”然后是我的名字和日期。回到爸爸身边后，邦妮过上了相当正常的生活。她开始上学，上了大学，最终成为了一名护士。她现在有两个孩子。她真的很幸福。她是牛奶盒活动中少数几个成功的故事之一。我相信我之所以成为今天的我，是因为我曾登上牛奶盒并被找到了，我在爸爸身边长大所获得的机遇可能是我在妈妈身边时无法拥有的。我能够过上美好的生活，对此我心怀感激。仅仅两年后，牛奶盒活动就结束了，但失踪儿童的
of missing children were still being printed on all kinds of other things. Pizza boxes, plastic rush re-bags, utility bills. Actually, the utility bill campaign went on for 10 years, much longer than the milk cartons. But most of us haven't even heard of it. It didn't stick the way that the milk carton did. Again, here's Paul Morsicchi-Renfro, the historian. It's one of those tropes with which we're all familiar, and it's appeared in novels, films, you know, there's a band called The Milk Carton Kids.
面孔依然被印在各种其他东西上。披萨盒、塑料垃圾袋、水电费账单。事实上，水电费账单活动持续了10年之久，比牛奶盒的时间长得多。但我们大多数人甚至都没听说过它。它没有像牛奶盒那样深入人心。再次说明，这位是历史学家保罗·莫尔西基-林弗罗。这是我们都熟悉的那些老套路之一，它出现在小说、电影中，你知道的，还有一个乐队叫“牛奶盒少年”。
There was something different about seeing a face on the side of a milk carton that really struck a nerve. There is a sense of familial unity that I think milk helps to author maternal nurturance and also being this kind of item around which people gather around the breakfast table. So putting missing kids' faces on that item was quite deliberate and perhaps the reason why that lives on. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Annie Brown with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan,
在牛奶盒侧面看到一张脸有些与众不同，这真正触动了人们的神经。我认为牛奶有助于建立母性的滋养，并且作为一种人们聚集在早餐桌旁围坐的物品，它带有一种家庭团结感。因此，将失踪儿童的面孔印在该物品上是相当深思熟虑的，这也许就是它得以延续的原因。《99%隐形》本周由安妮·布朗与凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘制作，
Avery Troll from Inkert, Colessted, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW, Sam Franciscoerenses going and produced out of the offices of Harksine in architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. We're all on Twitter, Instagram, Spotify, Tumblr. If you name it, we're probably on it. But you're always welcome in our place at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX.
艾弗里·特罗尔来自英克特，科尔·斯泰德，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7KALW的项目，并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Harksine建筑与室内设计事务所的办公室里制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们在Twitter、Instagram、Spotify、Tumblr上都有账号。只要你能说得出名字，我们大概就在那里。但随时欢迎你来到我们在99pi.org的家。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。